though it made her career Megan Fox's
experiences filming the first two
Transformers movies had huge
consequences on her professional life
and her relationship with director
Michael Bay there's no doubt that Megan
Fox is a talented and beautiful actress
she was declared the sexiest woman in
the world in a 2008 online poll and
seemed to be on top of the world after
she scored the role of Michaela Baines
in Paramount's Transformers box and her
co-star Shia LaBeouf received major
attention for their roles but there was
a moment when the actor's career took a
turn for the worse Hollywood is a
fast-paced and ruthless place which
means that if an actor or actress makes
a comment they shouldn't have or a
personal move they might regret it will
unfortunately stain their career in some
way or another for Fox it all started
when she said something that might have
gotten her canceled had it happened a
few years later in the so-called cancel
culture era of course everyone makes
mistakes and fox knows that today but
the toll it took on her is undeniable
Fox's career didn't start with the
Transformers franchise but it definitely
boosted her stardom it seemed like she
was on her way to becoming an a-lister
until 2000 9 when she sat down with
Wonderland magazine and talked about her
time on set with Transformers director
Michael Bay when she was asked what it
was like to work with the Blockbuster
King she said he's like Napoleon and he
wants to create this insane Infamous
madman reputation he wants to be like
Hitler on his sets and he is following
her comments Fox was booted from the
Transformers franchise with her
character being written out of 2011's
Transformers Dark of the Moon Fox's
Fallout from the billion dollar series
was controversial leading to a turbulent
case of he said she said following the
news Fox's PR team Came Out Swinging
saying that the actress wasn't fired
from the role with the decision to quit
being all her own shortly after Michael
Bay told GQ that executive producer
Steven Spielberg compelled him to Fire
Fox for her comments Shia LaBeouf added
that fox was let go because she started
quote talking the film's captain
ultimately Fox and base spat was
short-lived as they ended up working
together in the live-action reboot of
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles which Bay
produced Fox never took a break or quit
acting she maintained a constant low of
rolls but it seemed like her career
wasn't the same after her time on
Transformers was wrapped up it's not a
secret that some movie stars often get
Typecast into one type of genre this is
unfortunate of course and in the late
2000s Fox was feeling it that's weird I
just wouldn't pay you for mechanical
well you know I don't really broadcast
in a 2009 interview with Jimmy Kimmel
she explained how she felt sexualized
from the beginning of her career
particularly in her brief moment in Bad
Boys 2. FOX also starred in the Diablo
Cody Penn horror movie Jennifer's Body
which gained backlash due to the sexism
that surrounded it since then the
project has become a horror cult classic
there's no hidden truth behind Fox being
cast as the hot girl in an interview
with E.T Cody and fox reunited and
chatted about the film Fox revealed that
the pressure of being objectified and
over-sexualized took a toll on her which
stemmed from her role in Transformers
since her iteration of the Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles franchise wrapped
up in 2016. Fox hasn't worked with Bay
her most notable role since then has
been her stint on New Girl of course
there is always more to every story
about her comments about Michael Bay's
directing techniques and major
typecasting are just a couple of reasons
why Fox was never the same after her
role in the Transformers franchise
[Music]